大家好,欢迎参加本课程,我是蚂蚁蜜酸的开发,我叫文愿,非常荣幸能够向大家介绍,引语开元版pad。
本次课程主要分成以下几个部分,第一部分简单介绍一下secretpad,主要包括产品的定位,产品的架构,后续我会把secretpad简称为pad。
第二部分是快速上手,将给大家演示pad接电的安装部署以及如何创建、运行、训练流。
第三部分是按理分析,会向大家介绍如何使用pad为联合穿人以及金融风控两个场景提供解决方案。
第四部分深入剖析,向大家介绍pad与引语其他产品之间的关系,以及pad的架构。
第五部分介绍一下开元版pad的规划,下面让我们进入第一部分pad的介绍。
首先我们来讲一下pad的定位,pad的用户主要可以分成两大类,第一大类是直接使用者,第二大类是开发集成者。
对于直接使用者来说又可以分成两小类,对第一小类用户来讲得益于拖拉拽的交互方式pad很容易上手,既适合用户自己体验,也适合向他人演示,比如现在的我。
对第二小类用户来讲,pad提供的能力可以直接解决业务场景问题,这类用户可以直接使用pad进行研发,并用于实际生产,实际上pad在业界已经有了比较多的实际应用。
而对于第二大类用户来讲,开发集成者,pad已有了功能是无法直接满足他的业务需求的。
这个时候pad则起到了最佳实践样本间的作用,开发者可以参照pad把益于底层的能力集成进自己的系统。
而得益于益于的优秀设计,开发者仅需满足标准化接口,就可以集成,从而对不同行业进行商业化定制。
介绍完pad的定位,我们再来看看pad的产品架构分层,以及不同的合作模式。
pad的产品架构可以分成四层,第一,存数据接入业务运营层,这一块的话蚂蚁,以及银语基本上是不参与的。
第二块产品方案层,这一层银语pad总结了一些常见的解决方案,其实主要就是联合券人还有金融风控。
第三层隐私计算平台层及pad层,第四层隐私计算软子服务,主要包括了secret flow,枯下等能力。
我们可以再看看右边的这三个举行框,就在这里,对。
对于最左边的用户来讲,银语pad提供的解决方案,就可以满足它的业务需求,业务方直接使用就好了,比如说联合券人这个场景。
而中间的用户pad提供的这两个解决方案并不能直接满足需求,它就需要基于pad进行开发。
最右边的要求是最高的,pad的现有能力并不能满足需求,它们只能直接集成底层的算子。
其实我们可以看到,左边这两个模式其实就对于上叶PPT的第一大的用户,而右边的这个模式就对于上叶PPT的第二大的用户,集成开发者。
OK,现在我们进入第二部分,快速上手。
首先介绍下安装pad的软硬件要求。操作系统的话,Mac、Linux、Windows都支持,但实际使用中不可推荐使用Windows系统。
然后硬件是需要8核16G、200G的硬盘。Docker是必须的推荐20.10.24或更高版本。
好了,确认自己的系统符合要求后,大家就可以去引语官网下载对应的安装包并解压。
进入了解压目录后就可以安装部署。我这里是以Linux下P2P模式的安装部署为例的。
我会安装两个autonomy节点,分别叫做Alice和Bob。
我的安装脚本也已经提前准备好了,只需要执行即可。
好,现在给大家播放一下之前录制好的安装视频。
这是我们的安装命令,具体每个参数的含义,大家可以通过Install脚本的GunHelp命令得到。
这里我们简单介绍其中的几个,一个是autonomy,表示我们以P2P模式安装部署节点。
第二个GunAlice,表示我们节点名称是Alice。
第三个GunS8081,以及第四个GunP8084,这两个的话我们后续会用到。
好,我们现在执行脚本。整个过程大概需要一分多钟。
如果需要的话,大家可以跳过。这里的话我们不需要保存,直接选择N。
请大家耐心等待,或者快进。
全新安装依然选择N。
我们可以使用默认的机构名,也可以使用默认的用户名Admin。
密码的话需要输一个符合规则的。
我这里直接使用这个,需要输入两遍。
大家可以看到,登录名Admin,然后密码也是刚才设置的。
然后可以看到整个安装时间90秒1分半。
然后这个告诉我们如何访问。
8081,但因为我这个是用的服务器,
所以我需要拿到服务器的出口IP,8.130.66.88。
这个因为我之前已经访问过了,所以我直接在这里访问就行了。
然后我输入刚才设置的用户名和密码,然后登录成功。
好了,这样的话,我们的Alice节点就安装成功了。
Bob节点的话可以用相同的方式。
同一个机器上的话,我们只需要把对应的各个端口修改成不一样的即可。
好的,通过视频中的操作,我们已经安装好了Alice和Bob两个节点了。
现在就可以添加合作节点。
大家现在看到的就是添加合作节点的界面。
这里面除了通讯地址需要修改,其他都不用。
从这张图上,大家可以看到它的是支持多个通信协议的。
图中显示的是MTRS,也支持NoTRS。
对于MTRS协议,通讯地址的前坠需要为HTDBS。
端口号就是刚才部署脚本中配置的杠P参数,
派的人还提供的一键添加合作节点的功能。
在配置完通讯地址后,复制这里的节点认证码。
在对方节点添加合作节点页面粘贴即可。
对,就是在这个地方。
此外,出于安全性的考虑,添加合作节点是需要双向收船的。
操作上讲就是Alice需要把Bob添加为自己的合作节点。
Bob也是需要把Alice添加为自己的合作节点。
这个在后续的实操视频中,大家也可以看。
好了,添加完合作节点后,我们就可以创建合作项目。
这里我们可以看到是可以灵活的选择多组节点的。
就这里我可以本方节点,可以选择对方节点也是可以做选择的。
创建完合作项目后,下一步就是准备数据。
派的人支持多组数据员,比如说本地,还有OSS, ODPS, MyCircle等。
在pad里面,数据的受损力度是细化到了项目的,本地数据。
完成上述步骤后,就可以创建任务并执行了。
我们可以简单介绍一下任务相关的功能。
第一的话,支持普通任务,也支持定时周期任务,
然后有丰富的组建选择,比如说很多的日出礼,训练以及预测组建。
其他的就不一一介绍了,大家可以自行体验。
下面介绍一下模型发布。
当用户训练好一个模型后,就可以打包并发布,从而直接用于生产环境。
这里的话也是有比较多的东西可以配置的,大家可以看到。
CPU、自然都可以配置的。
好的,我现在就给大家播放下从天家合作节点到自行训练流的视频。
我们已经分别登录了Alice这个节点,以及Bob这个节点。
第一步的话,我们要天家合作节点。
天家合作节点的话,我们是要修改它的通顺地址。
我们先看一下通顺地址通过if-fig的命令。
然后gmp的端口号是8084,因为采用了http-m-tls协议,所以我们要加上https的前坠。
我们把Alice的通顺地址修改正确,然后同样需要把Bob的通顺地址修改正确。
这里除了gmp的参数不一样,其他都一样,8184。
好,我们现在在天家合作节点,将Bob添加为Alice的合作节点,需要在Alice操作。
可以看到计算节点这是Bob,然后本方节点我们选择Alice通顺地址,好,确定。
OK,我们需要再次把Alice的添加为Bob的合作节点用相同的方式。
对方节点本方节点就是要Bob了,好,确定。
可以看到通顺状态已经从不可能变成可用了,也是可用了。
合作节点添加好以后,我们就可以创建项目了。
项目的话我们给个test名称,描述不需要,可以不填。
本方节点我们填Alice,然后受到节点我们就填Bob,点击创建。
创建一个项目的话是需要对方节点同意的。
所以我们进入Bob的节点,然后点击同意,当然你可以。
这个时候因为项目还没有任何授权的数据,
所以没法进行任何的工作,我们来添加数据,给Alice添加一个Alice的数据。
然后可以看到它的特征,名称很少,因为是测试用的。
我们需要把Alice这张表受传给test的这个项目,
同样在Bob这一测也要做相同的操作,添加数据,添加一个Bob的数据。
名字同样时候受传,然后确认。
OK,这样完成以后的话,我们就可以进入项目,然后创建一个训练楼了。
这里我们以联合全人受传的Alice,关联键的话是I-D1,
项目表Bob,关联键的话是I-D2,然后特征的话我们就选择所有的特征,
结果接入方我们两边都选上,然后需要保存,保存完以后我们点击全部执行。
绿色的勾表明组件的执行是成功的,然后这个穿穿表明组件正在执行中,已经执行成功了。
好了,体验完派的基本安装操作流程后,我们就进入第三部分,
按理分析,进一步介绍如何使用派的完成联合全人金融风控的任务。
首先,我们可以先宏观的了解一下派的的应用场景,从这张图中我们可以看到,
从产业角度来讲,派的是可以广泛应用于不同领域的丰富场景的,
比如说银行业的智能风控,保险业的荷包礼配,还可以用于政务,医疗,交通,媒体等各个行业。
从社会角度讲,派的可以用于链接不同的行业实体间的数据孤岛,从而释放数据要素价值。
好,刚刚讲完了那些高大唱的,我们再来看看联合圈人,也可以叫营销圈人这个场景。
首先,向大家介绍一下这个概念,以保险公司和蚂蚁的合作为例,大家都知道保险公司肯定是有自己的客户数据的,
而蚂蚁集团也是有自己的客户数据,这两份数据的用户通常会有一部分重合,也有一些不重合的,
而保险公司会希望在不获取蚂蚁客户距离信息的情况下,找到和自己客户重合或者不重合的部分,
从而进行更精准的营销,这个我们就叫它营销圈人,要解决营销圈人场景的问题,
主要用到的就是隐私囚交组件,对大家可以看到就是这个组件。
现在我们就稍微介绍一下隐私囚交组件,可以看到这个组件是有三部分的,
这一块就上面的这两个点点穿穿,叫它的输入装,
然后下面的这个叫它的输出装,然后右边的这块叫它的输信,输信也可以理解为配置,
实际上派的所有的组件都是由这三部分组成的,
隐私囚交顾名思义就是在不泄露各方隐私信息的情况下,
获得双方的交集还是以保险公司和蚂蚁的合作为例,
假设保险公司用户身份证号分别是零一二一直到十,
而蚂蚁用户的身份证号分别就是比如说八九十一直到一百一千,
那么隐私囚交的结果就是八九十,
然后我们介绍一下隐私囚交这个组件比较重要的属性,
比如说右边的KISS SE和KISS S2其实就对应了我们刚才讲到的那个身份证号,
然后不同的囚交协议的话是用于不同的场景可以看到了,
比如说有了协议它更适合于高贷款的场景,
所以我们还可以选择囚交类型,
InnerJoin等等还可以选择结果的接收方,
简单了解了隐私囚交组件后,
我们再来看一下金融封控这个场景,
也可以叫做二分类建模,
比如说一家银行它需要判断某个人是否有违约风险,
从而决定是否发放贷款信用卡给这个人,
而因为一家银行掌握的这个用户的信息是有限的,
或者说它根本就没有为了提高分类的准确性,
它就可以结合其他第三方比如说蚂蚁的信息来进行联合建模,
从而提高准确性,
当然前提是不泄漏蚂蚁的用户信息,
从这个图中我们可以看到联合金融封控场景下,
它的这个解决方案要比联合圈要复杂很多,
里面涉及到的组件有十几个,
主要包括预处理模型选择和模型评估三大块,
预处理的又可以包括像WE分享,
一场是填充,特征选择等等。
因为在金融封控场景下,
正如刚才讲到的,它通常是要得到的是Yes or No这种结果,
所以常用的模型是Logistic Regression,
XGB这类的二分类模型,
这也是我们称之为二分类建模的原因。
最后一块是模型评估,
PAD提供了像P4评估,
K4AOC等常见的评估手段。
哦,相信经过刚才的学习,
大家对PAD已经有了比较深的感兴认知,
下面我们将有表极力深入一点,
了解PAD盈喻的架构。
这个就是盈喻的架构图,
可以看到整体采用的是分层的架构,
PAD是位于整个架构的最上层,
是整个盈喻的对外窗口,
PAD的下面是调度层,
我们称之为枯下。
理论上PAD只需要关心与枯下的交互,
其他底层像AI BI算法层,
设备层,
安全协议层,硬件层都不需要关心。
正是由于这种设计,
让前面,
第一部分所讲的开发集成者,
可以方便快捷了集成,
盈喻底层的各种能力。
了解了盈喻的整体架构,
以及PAD在其中的位置后,
我们再来看一下PAD的内部结构,
PAD主要是可以分成前端和后端,
前端提供用户界面,
比如大家之前看到的拖拉拐等功能,
后端管理业务层的数据与领域实体,
它与调度层的枯下连接,
构造,以及下发联合任务,
并需要从中获取结果。
PAD的后端是通过枯下API,
来使用调度层的数据,任务流等管理接口,
来实现刚才讲的任务下发,
以及结果同步功能的。
现在我们简单看一下PAD的工作流程吧。
首先,当用户创建项目任务流并点击执行后,
前端就会发起一个Start Graph的请求,
PAD的后端会拿到前端的数据,
组装成符合要求的教补,
并调用枯下API的Create,
Create 教补,
接口创建教补,
而枯下创建教补后,
才会调用对应的,
比如说Secret Flow,
Circle等完成最终的任务。
在这个过程中,
PAD是需要监控,
教补的执行情况以及结果的,
这就需要PAD调用枯下的,
握起教补接口来监控教补。
当教补执行完成后,
枯下会发送相应的事件,
而PAD则会监听到这个事件,
从而调用Sync job,
Sync result 接口,
获得教补的执行结果,
并返回给前端,
最终展示给用户。
这里也是一些代码,
大家有兴趣的话,
可以在倉庫里面看一下。
好了,
现在我们进入最后一部分的展望。
长远来看的话,
螞蚁密算是希望构建一个
跨人跨端的互联互通网络,
让各行各业的数据
能够安全自由的流动。
为了实现这个目标,
并结合不同用户的需求,
PAD在今年推出了标准版。
相比开软版、标准版
提供了运为监控等企业提供,
两个版本将互为补充,
分别服务于不同用户,
共同作为密算端,
服务于数据要素流通的大产业当中。
以上就是本次课程的全部内容。
感谢大家的参与。
谢谢。